we're kicking it off with the latest
trend in fashion cosmopolitan reports
that tennis outfits are
everywhere on or off the court tennis
skirts and polos are the latest look for
spring
ross could you get into this look well
not the skirt i don't think i can pull
it off but i i love this look and uh
even you know in palm springs
shorter shorts for men too are all the
rage
and uh um i think it's cute i can get
behind it i grew up in the era of
dolphin shorts like aka picture richard
simmons because he pretty much cornered
the market on them no describe a dolphin
short it's a short
it's like um they're basically
yes it's shocking any man can keep their
package in them
is what you need to know they're this
short and then they have like a little
cutout here so they sort of like flap
yeah
the first time i saw one was in a pair
of dolphin shirts really
oh yeah uh-oh escaped
i was like oh that's what they look like
i think it's sort of taking this like
athleisure thing that we've really
embraced during you know
the pandemic and and taking it to the
next level
you're right like where does athleisure
go from here
and i think the whole tennis thing is
super cute never mind i can pull off the
skirt
all right all right hey question have
you ever stayed up late watching like
netflix or reading
uh news on your phone when you know very
well you should be sleeping like a
little lamb
well there is a name for that and it's
called revenge
bedtime procrastinating and huff post
reports we do it when our days are so
busy that
we're fighting for some leisure time at
night it is an act of
revenge to get more time for yourself
but the byproduct
of this cycle is that we're all warmed
over piles of mud the next morning
because we've just stayed up when we
should be sleeping
but there is and i know you've done it
too where you are just like
this is my time i'm going to read the
stories i want i'm going gonna play the
game i want check the instagram
i want do you do it i am so guilty of
this
that i was actually shocked we haven't
had this conversation
sooner that like that it's only now
getting a name
because like this is something we do
and if you're a parent also
it's like when your kids finally go to
sleep you're like oh i need to live an
entire lifetime
and then you're exhausted the next day
lather rinse repeat but don't you think
there's something healthy about it too
sure you shouldn't do it every night so
you're exhausted but
i think it is important to take carve
out a little time to do the frivolous
stuff that just feeds your mind and your
soul
check that instagram you love do the
thing i think there's value in it
do you mind telling me that tomorrow
morning when i show up at work haggard
from a night of scrolling
yeah i'll be like oh looks like you had
some you time last night
it's so true though and you're right i'm
gonna have your inner dialogue in my
head rather than mine yours is much
nicer
just do a little balance like just
enough and then hit the hay ross
yeah do you remember what you ate on
your first
date with wellington uh yeah we were in
mexico and so we went to get tacos we
met in the pool and then had lunch and
got tacos oh
thank you so romantic yeah makes me
hungry too i know
um interesting okay well let's analyze
that data
so best life reports a new survey claims
that what you ate on your first date
could be a predictor
of the likelihood of your divorce what
what do they say about tacos
you're good okay they surveyed 5
364 people who had been married
and hilariously say if you had indian
food for dinner
you're doomed excuse me and first daters
who dined on samosas and nons had a 67
chance of divorce you know what that is
divorce that's a non-issue
[Laughter]
first daters who went with some steak
and potatoes
american fare if you will had a 59
divorce rate they had a beef with each
other
those who went for chinese food were at
a 55
divorce rate i mean what okay
i this is just kawinkidink don't you
think there's there's nothing to this
well indian and chinese are two of my
favorite foods and i've been divorced
three times
so i don't know just like hearing this
and being superstitious will you go on a
first date and getting on
well i never have to get married again
so sure understood thank you so much
good answer it's it's nonsense
come on that was great
[Music]
you